right now volunteers from across our
state are in Florida ready to assist
along with more than 500 Red Cross
disaster relief workers from around the
nation they want to make sure that
everyone impacted by the storm has a
safe place to stay food to eat relief
supplies and emotional support executive
director Rachel Flanagan says our
volunteers move supplies into place late
last week to be able to accommodate 60
000 people initially
a lot of our folks have deployed to the
Orlando area just to be away from the
storm and then they're going to work
their way towards those zones it looks
like they're on standby but we will more
than likely be deploying our emergency
response vehicle which is our big
feeding truck that we have that will
more than likely be leaving southern
Nevada here towards the end of the week
to deploy to that region as well all the
trucks in the country are actually on
standby
Flanagan reminds everyone to also donate
blood depending on the severity of the
storm more blood may be needed in the
Florida area now if you would like to
help people impacted by this storm visit
redcross.org call 1-800 Red Cross or
simply text the word Red Cross to 90999
to make a 10 donation we do have all
this information as well as a link to
the American Red cross's site to help
out as a whole on our website